one of my favorite games is beyond good
navel and one of my favorite parts of
that game is seeking out new species to
photograph a couple of those species are
absolutely enormous whales that can be
found way out in the seemingly empty
endless ocean I absolutely had to have a
picture of them but I remember feeling
terrified at the prospect despite being
a person with an irrational fear of open
water I still have a deep respect and
wonder associated with the alien
otherworldly place and its inhabitants
observe feels like it wants to share its
love of the ocean with you along with
its love of all things within it you're
able to explore the watery depths
alongside sea creatures discover the
names of the ones you find and even ride
the backs of animals that are serene or
inspiring and for me a little terrifying
the game is underpinned by an Austin
Wintory composed orchestral soundtrack
that constantly reminded me of Disney's
Fantasia I didn't expect I could come
out of a video game with a fondness for
great white sharks or longing for more
time in the dark underbelly of to see
but that's absa and really it does about
a job speaking for itself
Oh
Oh